I realized that there are a lot of
people who don't talk about what
happened to them I was one of them I
didn't talk about it hi I'm Louise and
this is my story I'm Riley and this is
my story
[Music]
before I watched 13 reasons why I barely
told anything about myself like I don't
want to be known as the girl that got
raped I just want to be known as Louise
going throughout high school I was
dealing with this very abusive and toxic
relationship being belittled and
threatened by the person I trusted most
in my life and I didn't want to live for
a good portion of my life I fell into a
depression I had a lot of anxiety like
no one understood what I was going
through because like no one's ever told
me that they've been through the same
thing I didn't tell my family or my
friends or my teachers and I kept it to
myself because I thought it was my own
problem when I first watched 13 years
and so why I struggled with a lot of
things that Hannah Baker went through
within the show so I found a lot of
relevance her Dean of Students came to
us with this idea for 13 reasons why not
for 13 consecutive days one person from
our school would come over the
loudspeaker and share a story of
emotional vulnerability of a time they
did not feel good enough and we really
wanted to reiterate the idea that
there's 13 reasons not to take your own
life there's over a million reasons not
to take your own life
[Music]
I related the most to Jessica's
situation in particular because that's
pretty much exactly what happened to me
to see something that was so close to my
experience was shocking after watching
that last episode I realized that there
are a lot of people who don't talk about
what happened to them I just felt like
people needed to know that I went
through the same thing it's okay to talk
about it so if you don't know my story I
am a rape victim survivor whatever you
want to call me and there's not a day in
my life that it doesn't affect literally
affects everything I do every single day
the reaction that I got from the video
was actually quite positive people even
DM me saying hey I've been through the
same exact thing I'm so glad you told me
about it
I feel comfortable talking about it
because you did to the whole world now
they they have someone to talk to like
they can talk to me as soon as my tape
Aaron I had people coming up to me in
the hallway to share their own stories
and we just saw the progression of
compassion we saw flowers being left in
classrooms and in bathrooms notes on
walls saying you are loved you're
beautiful you're strong there's a reason
you are here thirteen reasons why is
powerful because it started that
dialogue
[Music]
just talking about it that alone lifted
a weight off my chest I'm not terrified
to do things anymore now I see myself as
you went through something horrible and
you came out on the other side okay so
I'm so proud I'm just happy I'm okay
your story gives you power and it gives
other people power who are listening to
you there is a lot of healing through
sharing your story with others it's okay
if you're not ready some people it's
just not their time yet but when you are
ready it takes one person to tell and
you'll be okay
[Music]
[Music]